dans les décombres de la tour de
télévision de rivne les corps d'une
vingtaine de ses gardiens
le gouverneur régional a promis de
rétablir l'antenne sous deux jours et a
fait l'éloge des secouristes
27 novembre
sous les studios de télévision du centre
ville la cave où est stocké le vieux
matériel est devenu un abri rivne elle
même n'a pas été touchée mais le son des
sirènes et quotidien
le bris est aussi utilisée par les
voisins du quartier comme au legs
projet tout en optimisant mon amour une
fois l'alerté levée il nous habite chez
lui n'est donc à la nature et pour
savoir d'où je pars joie et noir une
petite chasse comme nous de constater
chez robic sonores en ville les
habitants peuvent capter la télévision
par le câble ou par internet
tetiana tout juste remonté de la bri se
prépare pour son journal
elle souhaite continuer à travailler
pourtant le journal diffusé le portrait
d'un volontaire locale qui conduit déjà
en pologne une destination qui est dans
toutes les têtes
jusqu'à présent les bombardements en
ukraine de l'ouest n'ont visé que les
infrastructures militaires et
stratégiques
mais ici chacun se demande si la
situation ne va pas s'aggraver comme
dans le reste du crâne
voilà on reste dedans